what should we start off with I think
one thing that uh kind of took the
entire internet by storm especially the
content creator sphere was the xqc story
yeah of uh how he signed a 100 million
dollar deal
which is [__] insane you know like
the one that shocked me the most about
that is like obviously 100 million
dollars a lot of money especially for
like a streaming deal but it's like it's
the fact that this man's deal was bigger
than LeBron James's
well blood money is an interesting thing
you see gambling money is different yeah
normal people money yeah it doesn't it
doesn't apply yeah yeah apparently that
was like a I mean it was it wasn't
confirm but it was very obvious that he
took some Equity yeah that the kick
which is a oh yeah full disclosure I
have a streaming deal with twitch yeah
not 100 million dollars yeah I think
full disclosure we would have heard
about it if it was full disclosure I
don't have a streaming deal uh at all
yes yes guys yeah full disclosure I
don't Stream
So with three different people I say it
blood money but my I have twitch is
Amazon so it's a different kind of blood
money yeah pissing the bottle money yeah
um as we said I think that one thing
that like kind of made me question
everything first was just like where was
kid getting this money and then I looked
into it and I think like steak.com which
is the company that gambling company
that owns kick I think like in the
correct me if I'm wrong mood on but I
think that like last year they were
worth like
a couple of billion dollars I think
they've made like 2.6 or something in
the revenue
something like that Jesus uh I mean it
just goes to show where like even you
know these like I guess when they play
like casino games they're like guys
don't don't do this I'm just I'm just
doing it because I need to get paid
clearly it works oh clearly let's say
that doesn't work yeah
I think people are just doing this and
playing slots mindlessly for hours
clearly has an effect it makes people
want to play these things yeah of course
I mean you're seeing it put right in
front of you and then you're telling
people hey you know this thing that's
right here in front of you yeah don't do
that yeah I mean I I have a feeling that
I'm not sure if this is going to be a
one-off deal or not just because I have
a feeling a few other craters as well I
don't know how much though I mean yeah
we don't know how much but obviously xqc
got paid this much and this was this
with this amount of money it's just like
a headline generator you know what I
mean you basically paid this much money
not just to bring what over one of the
you know the biggest streamer right now
in the in the pla on the platform on any
platform I believe uh to your platform
but also it's just 100 million dollars
in terms of marketing because this is
the most organic marketing you can get
because people are talking about it
everyone's writing about it and uh it's
now people are whether they like it or
not people are talking about kick
there's a massive massive cons of
conversation about Kik as a platform and
it's kind of like it's almost genius in
the way because even though like YouTube
is like obviously a much more
established platform it almost seems
like YouTube as a streaming platform is
just like the third party you know no
one's it's because YouTube's putting
like zero effort into trying to improve
the streaming experience on YouTube
it tries to I just think it doesn't know
what the [__] it's doing I don't think
it's trying as hard though as like
saying yeah I think the problem is is
trying to integrate streaming into a
into YouTube which is predominantly
video and the whole platform is built
around serving you video how do you kind
of integrate live streams in a way that
kind of works yeah uh and so but also in
general I mean I like that these big
deals are coming out this is good for
all of us and me specifically I'm very
happy exactly hey that means more
negotiating power kind of sitting in
there being like please yeah me next
please I mean you know if if if these
other companies you know because hackers
twitch twitch has made many many
blunders in the past year or two in the
past month or so I'd say this this
company this website
it's literally like just watching like
[__] Jerry going ham wait with Jerry
the mouse or Jerry's the mouse [__] Tom
happen on the rake walking into the
shotgun yeah it's like everything he
doesn't kick his Jerry and Thomas twitch
right now yeah and the thing the the
funny thing is uh you know even if
kicked wasn't doing these massive things
it just seems like a lot of websites a
lot of platforms are just having W's by
just doing nothing you know by just not
being twitch and making well if twitch
had done [__] nothing for the past
two years I think it'd be still be fine
but they [__] everything out
um it's so [__] I think as well the
about this xqc deal that just shocked me
was obviously you know the size of the
uh the contract as well but it's also
the fact that it's a non-exclusive so
this man literally just got 100 million
dollars from this website and then they
were like yeah you can continue to
stream switch actually I think I think
this is a
um this is a much smarter way of doing
it I think that when um from like Kix
perspective or any competitive because I
think we look at when like it happened
with like ninja and mixer there was like
a big thing for a little while but then
okay Ninja's on mixer people aren't on
mixer yeah right and then twitch uh
Ninja is now not on Twitch to kind of
like Usher people towards mixer right
yeah but if he's streaming on both and
you're a big viewer of the twitch
platform you like watching uh your
streamer on on Twitch or another
platform you know and you're let's say
every week of streaming twice a week on
both that's two times a week where you'd
be like hey guys you like this come come
to this other platform where I'm gonna
be doing it again tomorrow so I think
it's a way of kind of like constantly
making sure you're getting an ad on the
other platform yeah to your own platform
ad spot on Twitch for kick yeah and then
that way they can also then sell it to
the Creator being like no no don't worry
you don't have to you don't have to
abandon what you already have you can
still do it and also there's probably
it's probably easier for the streamer to
then take that
um because also probably less money for
them to have to pay but they're like
okay well it's not like a giant train
just like I don't have to stream twice a
week on that it's not a big deal it is
absolutely a big deal and you and it's
very hard to manage doing that but uh I
think that's the the Real Genius behind
the not exclusivity obviously we've seen
exclusivity from everywhere yeah but I
think having that is might might be the
future we'll see I think it's pretty
smart it's a very smart movie YouTube
doesn't need that [__] though because
YouTube's already got it on lock with
you with video streamers need their
videos on YouTube yeah I mean you
YouTube doesn't need to like invest to
get into the streaming space sure they
could be like a jack of all trades
master of one which is like the video
platform which is kind of what it is
right now you know YouTube shorts is not
hasn't taken off as much as like
something like say tick tock
um same with like the YouTube gaming
YouTube streaming it's just kind of
there it's just like oh you watch videos
well we have these other things as well
you know but it's not like it's never
gonna be known for that I don't think
YouTube is doing a lot of good stuff
though I uh stuff that I I as a streamer
I recognize I like it's pretty handy
like it used to be that
you know when you stream on a YouTube
channel uh that Vaude would just either
go unlisted automatically or just go up
yeah right but now they've separated it
so now it's home which can be like your
normal tailored videos highlights and
then there's live which has all your
vods yeah which is great because like
for right now for me on my twitch I like
I have a vlog Channel I have Eclipse
Channel I have a [__] shorts Channel
I have a highlight channel it's like all
this [__] is separate and YouTube is
slowly making it the one just stop for
everything yeah and that allows you to
kind of aggregate Subs as well whereas
all my Subs are all split in between
like 9 900 goddamn channels
I've also noticed it all just it also
makes it really confusing to see why
someone has subs you know sometimes [__]
yeah sure sometimes you go on a channel
they have like one million subs and you
see their latest videos and they get
like 10 KVs yeah you're like why the
[__] do you have oh and you click on the
shorts Tab and it's just like 10 million
views yeah 30 million views I was like
okay now that is true it does kind of
create confusion and like I feel you
know if you've been on YouTube for long
enough and you stumble upon a channel
like that then you automatically just
think oh they're either not active or
it's a dead channel so it's like you you
already have this kind of image so like
there are some good and bad sides to
that whole thing but um I I don't sub to
anyone on YouTube anymore
um I just thought the the
recommendations do everything now I have
stopped I I literally don't sub anymore
really I've noticed if I just watch a
channel enough it'll always appear on my
recommended I um I very rarely sub uh I
only sub if I know I watch something and
I'm like I want to make sure I remember
that I like this person yeah because I I
do the same thing I let my Rec I've met
like [__] AI recommendations I've
made it so that the sub is basically
useless yeah it's it's near it's not
like we make any money it's very very
close to being kind of defunct and just
this kind of nice fun number yeah that
certain creators it's a clout value but
do you notice that because your life is
like uh revolving around recommendations
that you always go into like certain
holes or certain like rabbit holes if
anyone like one random recommendation
you got on that week and you're like oh
that's actually a really interesting
topic yep and then you go that and
that's your rabbit hole for the week and
then you go to like the new rabbit hole
yeah yeah I've I've no which is why I
still do SUB to creators because just in
case that Creator is not in the rabbit
hole that I'm in for that week I'm like
I want to remember that I still like
this kind of content uh even even if I'm
not watching that Comic Con and I watch
too much content on YouTube to like go
back through my history to be like all
right where is it where was this one
video I saw that I really liked